foreign
I want to watch this guy change and turn
orange and pink and purple as day dies
in tonight
I want to hear the wind fluttering
through the leaves
and smell very faintly nag Champa Amber
incense but very faintly because scent
can be tough on a dying body
I want to die with socks on my feet
because I get cold and if I die with a
bra on I'm coming to haunt everybody
I will terrorize you and that is a
threat okay
I want to die in my own bed in my own
home with my loved ones nearby who are
talking amongst themselves and
comforting each other for this very big
thing that's about to happen in their
lives
I want to die with all of my Affairs in
order so my loved ones have nothing to
worry about but their grief after I die
I want to die empty devoid of all of the
skill gift talent and light that I carry
in this body
and satiated full of the richness of
this one unique human right
and when my loved ones notice that I
have released my last breath I want them
to clap
I want them to clap because I died well
but I died well only because I lived
well
now will it happen this way probably not
realistically I mean even with all this
rah-rah death talk I talk I'm probably
going to go kicking and screaming
unless we choose the date Place Manner
and time of our death will remain a
mystery then why think about it at all
death creates context for our lives
my entire life is leading up until that
point
how we die creates the period at the end
of the sentence but it is the period
that makes it a sentence at all
imagine for a moment your
847th birthday okay try I mean we
probably pushing 30 40 50 60 70 in this
room imagine 847 of them
so you're sitting there and your body is
raggedy Because unless they cure aging I
promise you you do not want to be
immortal I promise they're going to be
begging for death so with your 847th
birthday here they come with a cake no
candles on it because it would burn the
house down
and now here they come sing that same
tired song happy birthday to you you
would be so over it and if it was a
Stevie Wonder version that song is
already 45 minutes long you'd be extra
over it
nobody wants that nobody wants that we
count birthdays now because they're
finite they're special They Mark the
passage of time and one day we won't
have any more time and I find that to be
a really useful fact I think it's
healthy for us to think about our death
and you might say of course I do because
I'm a death Doula I wanted to embrace
thinking about immortality I spend a lot
of time thinking about talking about
helping people prepare and teaching
death through love
offer non-medical and holistic care for
the dying person
the circle of support and the community
through the process
I want to acknowledge first what a
privilege it is for people to be able to
know about and afford and hire a death
Doula we're working on it and next what
a privilege it is for me to even be able
to imagine my own death it says that I
have a sense of safety my basic bodily
needs are met and I have safety in my
body my mind and in my life even despite
the skin I wear
that wasn't always the case I came to
this work by Serendipity by circumstance
but mostly by necessity
a little over 10 years ago I was
practicing law at the legal aid
Foundation of Los Angeles and I grew
depressed not like oh my God I'm so
depressed but like for real depressed
like can't get out of bed depressed
can't shower depressed can't find Hope
can't find a smile but can't really find
Joy type of depressed I took a medical
leave of absence so I went to Cuba and I
met a woman there a fellow traveler on
the bus who had uterine cancer
we spent the 14-hour bus ride talking
about her life and also her death and it
was a highly Illuminating conversation
I heard firsthand how hard it was for
her to even be able to talk about her
fears around mortality and her disease
because people censored their own
discomfort with mortality rather than
make space for her
I took the invitation however to think
about my mortality and looked at my life
from the perspective of my death for the
very first time and it was Grim I did
not like what I saw
I noticed then that I had to live life
on my own terms because I was the only
one who was going to have to contend
with all the choices that I'd made at my
death
not long after I came back from Cuba my
brother-in-law Peter St John became ill
and not too long after that they
couldn't cure him anymore
so I went to New York where he and my
sister and my niece were and along with
Peter's family and my family and his
friends we ushered him to the end of his
life
being present for Peter's death is one
of the greatest gifts I've ever been
given
not only did I get to care for somebody
who I loved
so dearly
but it also grew my capacity for
compassion
I knew intellectually that there were
thousands of other people that were
walking through the same thing at the
same time
and it also hints that the thing that
I've been talking about in Cuba
everybody was uncomfortable with the
fact that he was going to die even the
medical care team
I knew that there should be somebody
somebody who was there somebody who
could be with us to walk alongside us
somebody who could listen to us offer
resources
hold our hands hold our hearts bear
witness to our pain help us sort through
information tell us that we were doing
the best that we could with the worst
that we were dealt
but I couldn't find anybody
so I became that someone for other
people
I sit deep in the trench with folks as
they prepare for death there's no fixing
or saving anything because there's no
fixing or saving grief or death it just
is I meet people where they are at
my goal is to help them answer the
question what must I do to be at peace
with myself so that I may live presently
and die gracefully holding both at the
same time
when I'm thinking about my present life
from the vantage point of my graceful
death I can see very clearly who I want
to be how I want to spend my time and
what of me I'll leave behind
it allows me to consciously curate my
life right now and also figure out my
little why's right now because what are
we waiting for anyway like death
I used to think dying people had it all
figured out though I used to think that
they'd lay there with their hands like
this because we all know this is like
Universal dying person pose so they'd
lay there with their hands like this and
there'd be a little glimmer in their
eyes they'd be like oh yes finally it
all makes sense turns out it's not like
that at all it doesn't look like that
Hollywood is lied to us you know that
already right Cinderella was
unconscionable but this is just flagrant
it's not like that at all it's way too
much work to be doing while you're dying
so it doesn't look like that there's no
secret there's nothing magically you'll
find out then this is it there's nothing
to figure out no big secret at all
many of my clients also reach the end of
their lives wishing that they had more
time but I'm always curious more time
for what what else would they do with
the time that they had it's rarely to go
see Machu Picchu okay I'll tell you that
can I tell you a story
okay so this client is a composite very
many clients shove together because as
juicy as their stories are it's not my
responsibility or job to tell them so
this is many clients together and it's I
find that it's an easy composite to make
because it's universally applicable this
applies whether or not somebody has
worked their entire life or sits on a
big trust fund or Works through jobs to
keep the lights on you might find bits
of yourself in this story
this client is somebody who had a decent
amount of privilege but not without
adversity of course because she's human
she had a great job great career had
been a real Trailblazer kids who she
loved who she was proud of good friends
travel the bunch did a bunch of great
things in her life had plenty of romance
and love she was doing okay she was
doing okay the girl who had everything
and then came a plot twist
that plot twist was an aggressive bone
cancer that was likely going to kill her
and what that thought twist came a sense
of pointlessness to her life
she couldn't figure out what she'd been
doing for the past 60 odd years because
she'd been so busy doing
while she was healthy it was about the
next career Milestone of what's
happening with the kids next or the next
trip when she was sick more of the same
next doctor's appointment next scan next
medication she was so busy distracting
herself from like the difficulty that
she found in her life staying out of her
body so that she didn't have to be
present with what was going on
it was always out there she was always
always looking out there but death was
coming to remind her that she had no
more out there that it was always only
right here where there is nothing at all
to do
but simply to be
we zoomed out on her life to look at
what she enjoyed to see where she plays
the value because from there we can
figure out where we place meaning
and turns out it wasn't about the kids
or the work or the money it was about
the little things
her hands in the soil
her garden
Building A Fire reading books and food
she loved to eat but she had dieted most
of her adult life it sounded all
familiar to anybody
okay if it does this is for you okay if
you take nothing away hear this you are
going to die so please eat the cake eat
the cake order the dessert eat the
french fries eat the brownies eat
everything you want to just eat it
because you're gonna die one day you
won't be able to anymore at this point
in her disease process chemotherapy had
ravaged her taste buds so she had to
rely on her sense of smell to get
pleasure out of eating and she ate she
did it as much as she could because she
knew she wouldn't be able to for much
longer
she ate as much as cancer would allow
and when her body could no longer
process food we placed her favorite
passion fruit souffle right on her lip
and she would lick it and smile
she lived more in that last eight months
or so of her life with the help of
hospice than she had before
she was finally present at home in her
body delighting in the richness of the
sensory experience we have by virtue of
these Fantastical bodies that we will
die in
these bodies that we will die in
she was also really curious about her
Legacy what if anything she'd leave
behind
but leaving a legacy is an optional
we're doing it every single day you're
doing it with every smile every word
every kind word every harsh word every
action every inaction every dollar you
spend
you're telling the people who are paying
attention exactly who you are and that
is what they'll tell of you when you are
gone
at her funeral despite all her career
accomplishments nobody talked about any
of that they talked about who she was
nobody cared about what she'd done
when we focus on our productivity
we highlight what we have to do to feel
worthy rather than who we get to be
where worthiness is our Birthright
and we are human
we're human we're human mentally
magically fantastically
beautifully briefly perfectly human
now humans are meaning making machines
we can make a story out of anything and
make it sound good
so why not then make meaning out of the
magic of the mundane
and absolve ourselves of the
responsibility of trying to have some
Grand life purpose
why not just give ourselves permission
to be fully human to be fallible to be
messy to be here while we're here
I mean there's nobody else tripping out
over the fact that we're on a giant blue
Rock spinning through space y'all don't
trip about that because I do regularly
yeah and then what really trips me out
is that while that's going on we're
getting bent out of shape over traffic
please let the cars merge okay can we
agree universally we're going to let
people merge let them merge let them
merge let them merge it take it requires
nothing of you just to give them a
little bit of time in fact it's probably
taking more time off your life by all
the high blood pressure when you don't
want to let them merge just let them in
it'll be fine everybody's fine
it's okay it's okay hold life lightly
we've got to hold life really really
lightly we are all dying we're all dying
now I can understand why people maybe
don't want to talk about death or think
about it it's uncomfortable it's sad
it's scary icky
acknowledging your death means that you
are not the center of the story and that
is disquieting to the very fragile human
ego
acknowledging your mortality also means
acknowledging our powerlessness and lack
of control we have in life also icky
it also means surrendering to the big I
don't knows of life and also the really
big I don't knows of what if anything
happens after we die
but since we don't know why not imagine
something absurd
something glorious something huge a
vision that actually serves you rather
makes you want to recoil in fear
we could
you want to hear my working Theory
it's absurd okay and please remember
even though I might kind of look like
Miss Cleo I don't know anything about
what happens after we die all right this
is just this is just an idea Okay so
I'm on my desk bed on the outside they
are clapping
on the inside well I've hit my death
pose all right I'm in my death pose
on the inside I'm starting to feel
everything I ever felt in this body all
at the same time it's all starting to
gather up in my body all at the same
time like that one time I was 11 and I
stepped on a frog I mean poor frog and I
felt so bad but I was barefoot ill like
I can still feel squishing up between my
toes
when you bite into an orange and the
juice squirts into your mouth and then
there's a little bite in your jaw oops
there's a little bite in your jaw
because it's sour or when you first bite
into a fried plantain
or getting into clean sheets that
feeling gathering in my body all the
feelings getting into a hot shower
listening to a song that you love for
the very first time I'm hearing Stevie
Wonder as playing how I feel my spirit
when I see the color yellow just all
these feelings are starting to roll up
in my body my niece's laughter my nephew
trying to teach me how to Dougie it did
not go well
it didn't go well I still don't know how
to do it
um how I can look into my partner's eyes
and just by looking into his eyes I can
feel love in my body all these feelings
are starting to gather up in my body
at the same time I'm also feeling every
little bit of pain I've ever felt
physically and emotionally I'm feeling
all the sensations I'm feeling anger
feeling rage feeling frustration feeling
grief feeling sadness
feeling all those things Gathering up in
my body I'm feeling despair desperation
sadness I'm feeling insecurity all the
crippling doubt I'm feeling all the
failures all the disappointments every
single time I thought I couldn't make it
through the day it's all starting to
gather from my body I'm also remembering
every single time I did get up so I'm
also feeling all the hope all the joy
all the all the mystery all the freedom
that I feel in this body but most of all
I'm also feeling all of the love all the
aching love that underwrites it all
and when I cannot take it anymore I am
saturated with this experience that I've
had poof I explode into a cosmic orgasm
yes
and like a pinata that's broken open
pieces of glitter start to fall from the
sky glitter confetti falling falling
orange pink purple
yellow turquoise everything gold silver
falling falling falling like a really
soft snow shower falling everywhere
in larger concentrations on the people
who loved me
and unless a concentration on those
people whose lives I touched
and then the rest of it just gets
reabsorbed into a big undulating glitter
wave that goes on all around as far as I
can see for all of eternity that
envelops and encompasses us all
maybe it's just glitter could it be
it could be anything
all I know is at that point all I
believe is at that point when the
glitter all the pieces of me have been
re-encompassed the eye that I think of
myself as
having this one single solitary Human
Experience has been re-enveloped into
all that ever was and all that ever will
be
and it is complete
and I am safe
I am so far from where I was in Cuba
at that point my death would have come
as a relief
an ending to my pain into my suffering
and a way out of this life that I
couldn't quite figure out how to get
into
if I'm to die today
I know that my death will come as a
celebration
as a culmination of a life lived in and
loved
a life that's worth dying from
after the last decade spent supporting
people
as they think through their lives and
prepare for their death
I know a trust that the real gift in
being with our mortality
is the sheer wonder that we live at all
that's all I got thank you
[Applause]